Holy kutch, what is wrong with you? Right now, that is reality
setting in on somebody who did not pay attention for the past
2 hours and they're realizing that they [__] up doing
it. He only sees that he's getting an audience, that he's getting
clout from this connection and he will defend anything and he
doesn't care to look into whatever it is. That's sick. This guy
is sick, man.
>> Okay, so what happened is Connor and Destiny had their
crash show. Connor said that he hates playing with the groper's
wife and they had this whole fight and all this, right? Connor
you come to find out that the guy, the devil guy, the thing he
told Connor was that this woman, his his wife, his ex-wife, whatever,
was doing some sort of age play where they she involved the right?
They were step parents like doing something to the And Connor
asked the wife about it and the wife said, "No, the husband's
just husband's just making it up cuz he like wants to win in
a breakup or he's mad and all of this and he's making it up."
So, Connor went on his merry way like told Destiny, "You shouldn't
engage with these kinds of people anymore. They obviously have
some problems and it's really bad, right?" It seems like the
allegation has come out that now Destiny got pictures of this
guy's too, which is crazy back in like I assume November before,
all
But come to like this month Connor realizes that Destiny is still
texting this woman, the woman who he thought was just doing age
play with him, some sort of babysitter, right? And then Connor
finds out that this woman wrote into Mr. Girl
and discussed like explicitly not not just age play, not just
babysitter stuff, but fantasizing about being the step parents
of each other's and involving the in the role play, okay?
And that changed Connor's mind basically immediately. Once he
found out that that was the allegation, that the allegation was
true and that Destiny had continued to engage with this woman
after Connor had called him out for it. And so that's like the
quick rundown of why Connor was so upset, why he felt the need
to go public with a bunch of this stuff. All right, without further
ado, we might go into the Hutch thing cuz that seems to be where
the content is.
Uh Hutch bot right here, let's get it
Let's get it going. >> I think there's hopefully
um a soul
or human being that is capable of >> redemption, kindness,
care, love.
Somewhere in there. It's deeply buried under all of the
But there's flashes of that. And I'm praying that eventually
the
of his kindness and grace
and virtues,
although he has many vices,
um I'm hoping one day he'll choose
to embrace his virtues and expand upon >> What's your analysis
so far?
>> This is Mr. Girl levels of crazy. >> It's hard
to take these comments as
you add the element of the fact that it's being live streamed.
>> Why? Why?
>> You know, like making a spectacle of it. It just really
>> These people knew each other primarily these live streamers.
Connor's reputation as a live streamer is being undermined significantly.
>> Really undercuts the tone. Like if he was saying these
things privately to to
>> He said them privately. >> And if they had the
kind of friendship where that sort of talk was where they had
a rapport where that kind of talk could happen and and that and
it would be like organic.
And uh like within the within the boundaries of their friendship.
But you
making a making a spectacle of it.
I don't know why Hutch makes he he literally makes a job out
of coming in uninformed and being told what happened and like
really up the analysis. Like you probably shouldn't be stepping
into this at all. If you just don't care, shut the [__]
up. If you're going to go and do this and it's like actually
serious for these people, have a little concern and look into
it. Like don't get things fundamentally wrong, foundationally
wrong from the outset just because some people were mean to you.
I am mean to Hutch because he's a [__] Yeah, I see
you. I see you looking into my soul Hutch right now. I see you.
Eyes right here, buddy. Okay, you're a
because you refuse to do any work for your job. You are a lazy
loser who shows up uninformed and then actually reacts to stuff
or or talks about stuff that's important and totally it up. Now,
are your really consequential in the grand scheme of the universe?
No. But they're a lot worse than a lot of other people's and
they're all within my space. So, I do dislike this guy. I don't
understand how he lets my dislike for him chase him into being
a [__] like a total puppet for other people. Why
not just watch the content, figure out what's going on and form
an opinion instead of just saying things like, "Oh well, well,
this should have been done in private." Yeah, it was, idiot.
>> Comes across as kind of cynical, which is a bit ironic
because he's accusing others of of uh
Destiny for clout, you know.
and it and it sounds like
he's convinced himself that this is like a loving act of friendship,
but again, it's the same sort of commentary as the last one,
which is these these conversations are
>> Wait, he did watch Connor say that he brought this up
in private already, right?
I believe.
So, it's not even that he hasn't seen >> you know what
I mean?
It's not normally how these kind of friendships go.
These kinds of exchanges go. Which brings [clears throat] us
to food shops.
So, since
was pretty open about Steven's >> No, I'm saying he watched
some of the previous conversations, ogre boy, and he would know
from the previous conversations that Hutch has brought it up
in private Sorry, that Conner has brought it up in private, because
he watched the previous conversations.
But my beef with food shops 2 years ago, my beef with food shops
3 years ago, my beef with food shops 6 months ago, my beef with
food shops 2 months ago, my beef with food shops now is that
she is an unrepentant all that. She looks at
He's been reading into her, but that seems to be it. Food shops
essentially became his Jstock. Food shops had 1,700 people watching.
Uh gotcha. Okay. Okay. Cartoon drawings of adolescents and she
listens to it. This has always made me uncomfortable. I have
>> Okay, so we just got a face. We've got a face. All right,
we've got a face. >> always just like this. Food shops
joked about suing me. She is welcome to do so. I will hire the
cheapest attorney that I can possibly find in order to respond
to the motions, and I will show up to court, and I will play
her own live streams for the court to hear.
She is a I'm confused. What's happening? >> What else is
he doing? What is he confused by? What else is going on? I watched
him just make a face. He sat there with a stupid face on for
30 seconds, and he goes
Wait, what's happening? >> ago, my beef with food shops
6 >> Dude, he is My god, he is a parody of himself. It's
like he's becoming dumber and making stupider faces as we go
along. Like as time goes forward, he more dumb and makes dumber
faces every single time.
>> months ago, my beef with food shops 2 months ago, my
beef with food shops now is that she is an unrepentant
She looks at cartoon drawings of adolescents and she listens
to This has always made me uncomfortable. I have always disliked
this. Food shops joked about suing me. She is welcome to do so.
I will hire the cheapest attorney that I can possibly find in
order to respond to the motions and I will show up to court and
I will play her own live streams for the court to hear.
She is unrepentant.
>> People are like, "Oh, the court won't allow that evidence."
I don't understand why why would the court not allow her statements
onto the record?
>> There are dozens of clips of her admitting to this behavior.
>> You heard it twice now, Hutch. So, go ahead, say it
loud and proud. Do you support this or not? >> I'm not
a fan that Steven chose as his
who thought the adolescent was
Now, breaking this down a little bit further because there will
be liberals who watch this stream. >> So, did he say he
didn't understand and now does he understand and he's going to
let it go by without speaking or >> I do not believe in
the Max Carson quote of you can fantasize about whatever you
Your brain, like a vital organ or a muscle, responds
>> Don't have her babysit your kids.
Dude, what? Dude, he's just talking about everyone's bad deeds
so he doesn't have to think about his divorce. Dude, I don't
even.
It's actually crazy watching It's crazy watching like the chat
won't even engage with this, right?
Even a Not even a little bit. >> And there's a concept
that I explained to Chud Logic several years ago called neuroplasticity.
It basically means >> He just paused so he listened to
something, heard Connor call this person
said, "I didn't quite get that." Went back about 50 seconds,
replayed the same segment, and did not give a take.
That's like only Hutch could do that. Nobody else in this business
is ever doing that. To watch almost a full minute of content
from somebody, pause so you didn't really pay attention, roll
back that full minute, watch the whole thing, and not even think,
oh, I should give a take on this.
>> Um, I went to bed, uh, as I do, 10:00 p.m., Netflix
and my programs, and and, uh, I opened up my phone and checked
YouTube real quick, and there was like a thumbnail of a streamer
that was talking about Livin' Learn drama, some debate. And I
listened to the stream, and, uh, FoodChops was defending me,
or whatever, and, uh, I didn't know anything about FoodChops,
and, uh, like, you know what? Why don't I call into the stream?
And so, that's what I did. I called into the stream. We had a
little >> His YouTube title was Hutch Defense Squad. So,
he was like name searching
And saw Hutch Defense Squad, and hopped onto the stream. >> conversation.
And, uh, I didn't I have I had no idea about like
consumption, or, uh, anything, you know, uh, she seemed pretty
harmless, and, uh, nice and all. >> You had no idea, but
then you were informed, obviously. >> me for a clip. She
asked me would I ever would I ever associate with Destiny ever
And I paused for a minute, and I said, you know I mean, sure.
I mean, I would like leave the door open for literally anybody.
And that was like that was like the gist of it. And then that
like started a whole thing.
Destiny had called in before then. Are you sure about that? [laughter]
Are you positive about that? >> He's like the dumbest man
anywhere in this sphere. It's so funny.
Like, I I feel like I should do, if I wanted to commit, I don't,
but if I did, I'd just do a drinking game, where I take like
a tenth of an ounce of alcohol every time Hutch is confused on
one of his live streams. I would die by the 30-minute mark.
I'd have taken like like a tenth of a shot every time. I'd have
taken like by the 30-minute mark, you got to figure 300 shots?
>> All that, I don't know if they had any
before then. I don't actually know, but
I I'm pretty sure that's how FoodChop, FoodChops, I think that's
the origin story there. And I talked to this gentleman, whose
current profile on Discord is called Devil. They engaged in step-parent
>> Um, FYI, this Devil guy comes on stream later, and walks
all of this [__] back in front of him, by the way.
So, this is a lie. Yeah, no spoilers. Why Why spoilers in the
chat?
>> Also, that's not true. That's like a lie, but Hutch
probably
because Hutch doesn't trust his own internal thought process
because Hutch is like he can't really put like connect dots himself.
He might just take that and run with it for the rest of the stream.
like I'm not joking that he doesn't really trust himself to identify
what's happening. And so the chat telling him that may actually
push him in that direction immediately.
>> That's the clip that I saw. >> I saw that clip
making the rounds. >> That they sent pictures of the family,
specific details unknown. That he was deeply deeply deeply upset
by this. That he wanted vengeance against Steven. Now, in the
text message logs, what I remember is that he was accusing this
person, his wife, of engaging in step parent role play. Of involving
pictures of their of engaging in lurid affair or depending on
your definition,
role play and how that was repulsive and disgusting and he hated
her and hated Steven for doing this and destroying his family.
So, to Wick
to Hutch
>> Why am I involved in this? Hang on. Why is my name coming
up right now? >> My Twitter might have gotten hacked, by
the way. My Twitter has already been banned once. So, I'm paying
a price >> for telling the truth, the whole truth and nothing
but the truth, so help me God, as I've seen it, as I remember
it. I decide, "Hey, I gave him a shot across the bow. I can't
tell who's telling the truth. I don't know if Steven is being
>> Let it go. >> And if he's pretending to be a year
old by a year old girl, which is weird.
>> Did he just say
I decide, "Hey, I gave >> Did he just say we got more faces
coming [laughter] out?
I decide, "Hey, I gave him a shot across the bow. I can't tell
who's telling the truth. I don't know if Steven is being a [__]
And if he's pretending to be a year old boy getting by a year
old girl, which is weird. But Steven's a weird guy, so whatever.
Or if it's worse.
So I'm going to put this in I'm going to give Steven a shot across
the bow. I'm going to ask the husband what he wants to do. Look,
Connor's claiming that that Did he see evidence of this or Is
Connor saying that that's what happened? No, Connor is saying
that the husband said this to him, but the wife says no.
And so he's going to say to Steven, "Hey, how about you stop
engaging with people who are doing this who are like telling
me about it or crashing out in in public about this? How about
you just don't do that Cuz it's it's actually like kind of
Right? So Connor doesn't expect that it's real cuz one of the
two parties is saying, "No, we broke up and like he's losing
it and it's whatever." So he goes, "Oh, well, it's a domestic.
Okay, I I'm probably not going to pay that much attention."
This is just off the top of my head
I have my own judgments, but they're they're just I don't I would
never
Like it's all very messy for me. I I'm in my settling down years,
so I look at that and I think, "Well, that looks pretty noisy."
You know? But I don't lose sleep
You don't think about it. You don't care about it, which is which
makes your commentary here like abhorrent. It makes it gross.
You don't care to be informed. You don't want to be informed.
If you don't want to be informed, then sit the [__]
down and shut the [__] up.
It's so simple. You know why I don't talk about the genocide
in Sudan?
Cuz I don't know about the genocide in
I'm not going to take a strong position on it when I got no idea
what the [__] is going on.
Sleep over it. I don't think about it basically ever.
Unless I'm watching a video like this and I'm forced to learn
things about Steven's life that, you know, I would have preferred
to not know cuz I just don't care. Like I have opinions about
it, but I don't like
think about it. It's not something that takes up any kind of
real estate in my
And Connor Connor seems to be saying
that you know, me and Wicker being obtuse because the you know,
Steven's like personal life is is what the snarkers talk about
a lot. Well, that's isn't that like our point? Like why are they
so focused on this guy's
interpersonal relationships and like romantic life?
>> Because he fans and co-workers and has done a lot of
harm to those co-workers and instead of admitting fault and trying
to make like give reparations or try to make amends, he has decided
to like try to break them off of the internet instead.
You said you knew Pixie. You said you'd hung out with Pixie at
some point. I assume you knew some of these people. I assume
you give a [__] about those people being hurt and
possibly getting some form of justice. If not through the courts,
then just literally somebody apologizing for wronging them. No?
Well, no, cuz you you claimed that well, you couldn't get back
with Destiny until he'd shown some remorse and he's shown no
remorse and you're hanging out with him again cuz you're a you
can't stand on your own and you'll always be a [__]
a stupid unfortunately who has to suck to make money. A stupid
dumb I shouldn't say actually.
>> This conduct is not private.
It is not.
We found out about Melina and Lauren Southern and Rose because
Steven sent his not only home made to Rose. He sent his love
letters to and from Lauren Southern.
Why are you sending love letters of you and your ex-girlfriend
to a worker you have known for 10 days?
If Steven's private life was private, then it would remain private.
If Steven's personal life was personal, it would remain personal.
But it's >> Why is he saying twerker? What does he mean
by that?
So, when Steven was getting catfished, the pretense was that
Rose was a twerker? Wait, what? Was an only fans model? Actually
not. And the same level of indiscretion that he engaged with
in reference to Rose. Are only fans models considered twerkers?
>> Uh one, yes, and two, this person is a hutch mod obviously
a DG G area. Oh, there she was an OF model. No, she
No, she wasn't.
Selling on Twitter not OF at hutch. They always do this. They
always just do it. It's so funny man. It's so funny and it it
might seem small but it's not in aggregate. It builds up to something.
>> Wouldn't twerkers be if you're a chud? You know what?
Let's ask Claude. No, you know what? Let's not ask Claude. Let's
uh skip forward in the video. >> Not only that but her
and her husband are broken up
But Steven thought it was prudent to receive
of the husband
and this wife.
I want you to understand that.
Britt vacillates between endless adoration and love for Steven.
She truly loves him on a fundamental level. She thinks he's the
best thing since sliced
Her husband has blamed Steven for the implosion of his family.
Steven received a video of these two mentally unstable homicidal
and
military veterans having for his personal enjoyment. That is
something that I was told on Saturday and by the way, that was
confirmed by both parties. >> What's the significance of
them being military veterans? Wait, what?
It is a little funny that Connor highlights that. I think it's
just to underscore how mentally they might be to be honest with
you which is a little weird given Connor's a military veteran
>> husband has blamed Steven for the implosion of his family.
>> Keep going. >> Um like okay. So my understanding
is that a lot of these allegations get kind of blown up later
in the stream by one of the parties that he's talking about here.
>> Is that your understanding? Is that what a chatter told
you 30 seconds ago? >> Well, probably like 30 minutes ago
now. >> I question the ethics of like let's say it was
all real, you know, let's say all of this was real. I question
the ethics of like let's say that these they're they're a couple,
they're two veterans, They have PTSD. They have self-unaliving
thoughts, this kind of Why would you blast this out in a live
>> Because he's having his like own reputation maligned.
Right? That he was concerned about this and he's basically being
told by a bunch of people around him, like this is his job and
his job is being undermined by people saying he's lying and he's
going, "Well, the truth will will set you free and this is the
truth."
He's basically been accused of lying like multiple times.
You could say, "Oh, well, none of this should have been made
public." But I do think he's actually concerned about several
different things here. One of them is his own concern, but I
don't think his own concern like is
him having his own concern here, it's not like he can't defend
his own business, right? Like I don't think that's fair to say,
"Well, actually, you need to just roll over and die cuz these
people are willing to lie and call you a liar. So, roll over
and die, Connor." I just don't think that's appropriate.
>> Why would you do that? If that if that was actually
true?
If if that was true, wouldn't blasting out their personal business
on a live stream like that potentially be a pretty significant
risk to those people if all that was true?
It just seems wildly inappropriate.
I'm going to guess that Connor's going to say that this seems
to be downstream of these people crashing out taking everybody
around Destiny in November when Connor originally sends him the
letter, right? That Destiny continuing that relationship means
that it will continue to come up again and again and again and
Destiny's the person putting them in the limelight. And that's
what he's upset about. And for Connor, I'm guessing there's some
added elements of like, "Well, if this is just going to keep
happening, I'm going to I'm going to talk about it
And I do understand this for some people. It's like
you want to let the person who lies and uses people in this way
continuously be the victor because he's willing to lie and keep
everything like he's willing to weaponize their their privacy
like concerns about their privacy,
no matter what happens, right?
I do get it. I I get how people get into that headspace.
Anyway, we we keep going. I I get how people get into the headspace
even if I might disagree with, you know, I it's it's a tough
one, man. The The thing makes this whole thing tough. >> That
is something that I was told on Saturday, and by the way, that
was confirmed by both parties.
That was confirmed by Brett, and that was confirmed by Devil.
So,
you can imagine, I hope, my frustration, rage, and anger that
my
who is $800,000
down because he was
is still being imprudent
in a way that could get him
and in a way that could result in a
I'm He doesn't understand the contradiction here?
So, there could even be a contradiction here. Like, I I understand
what Connor's talking about, but there could even be a contradiction
here, right?
There could be, but unfortunately, Connor basically
defended Destiny when this pattern played out the last time.
And now, he's asked Destiny, "I defended you here cuz I think
you're a good person, and I think ultimately we could be better
than this, and you could be better than this, and you can make
your whole thing work." And then Destiny immediately engaged
in the same pattern again, right? That's That's his problem.
And so, he might think that, well, actually sweeping this under
the rug doesn't really do anything good. It's just going to lead
to this happening again, and again, and again, and again, and
again.
And the sad thing is is the person who gets hurt hurt least in
all of these different instances seems to be Destiny.
You see a friend who's doing these self-destructive behaviors
that always burn somebody significantly more than they burn him.
I do understand why you having defended that at some point makes
you feel like defending it in the future would be bad, or even
keeping it under wraps in the future would be bad. >> So,
his whole line of attack here is implying that Steven's actions
put someone at risk. Put somebody mentally unstable at risk.
And then just like blast all the But he doesn't understand the
contradiction of like blasting all of this out on a live
The Snarkers have given me one thing
and one thing alone.
I have verified that this is Britt through information
that I have saved.
She wrote in to Mr. Girl's call-in show via email to discuss
her relationship with Steven. >> when he plays it? >> This
is confirmed.
I cannot be sued for this
because I have the evidence that backs up the truth of this scenario.
Let's listen. >> Okay, I would have to skip through some
of this. >> Oh, wait. No. >> in an online affair
with a guy for almost a year. My husband wouldn't engage with
any of the weird trauma-induced kink stuff that I was curious
about, and so I was compelled to impulsively and regrettably
regrettably engage with this guy online in some pretty intense
and taboo age play scenarios, including fantasizing about being
step parents to each other's and obviously >> This is Mr.
Girl reading it. Gotcha. Tahaj, thank you so much for the tier
one membership. Appreciate it. >> Obviously it went way
too far, but felt really intensely good in the moment. But afterward,
I felt sick and >> I mean,
asked the question of like whether or not the Snarkers were running
gayops in Connor's chat.
Uh, I don't know how much I can say.
But the answer is yes, that was happening quite clearly, explicitly.
>> and cried all night because
>> What were the gayops in Connor's chat?
Dude, Hutch, define gayop. Define gayop right now. >> If
you're saying that you doubt your willingness to hold boundaries
in real life, then that is dangerous. Yes.
>> The all caps just got >> I feel like I'm reading
um
Kevin Spacey >> Is it Are you really He Hutch just heard
that this person is considering letting
partner violate her
and Hutch is like, "Oh my god, are these all caps? Does this
guy type in caps lock in MS Paint?"
I don't want to undersell how psychotic this is that Connor did
his manifesto here in MS Paint. I don't want to undersell how
psychotic that is. But still, this is like the most important
part of the stream right now and Hutch is not paying attention
intentionally. I'm positive it's because he got told it was going
to get walked back.
That somebody in chat said, "Well, actually, it's going to get
walked back here." And Hutch just blanked. He just blanked. He
doesn't care. He's not going to pay attention to anything else.
>> Basically, these notes that they find at >> Seven
No, that's me. I have eaten foliage with $5. Amazing Connor didn't
consider Britt could have told that tale to both her husband
and this letter and therefore not really corroborated. I don't
really think I understand that. Cybex with $5. I will assume
none of this is walked back and it's none of my business what
two consenting adults do
As far as people's now, I'm not saying this is what actually
occurred, but as far as what two consenting adults do in terms
of role play stuff, I have
zero opinion on that stuff. I I don't understand the relevance
at all.
It could be the wildest role play you could possibly imagine.
And I just I don't think that's any of my business. Uh, you know,
like there's some kinks where I'm like, that's a little weird,
but I you know, I And if there's things that like in the past
people have like
asked me to do things that I wasn't comfortable with, but I just
don't I just don't care. I just I don't think
Again, is he just not going to engage? He's just not going to
engage at all. So, I also sent a DM here, but >> The all
caps just uh I mean, to both her husband and this letter and
therefore not really corroborated. I don't really think I understand
that. Cybex with $5. I will assume none of this is walked back
and it's none of my business what two consenting adults do privately.
As far as people's now, I'm not saying
>> Do we Do we not listen to what was just said?
Do we not listen to what was just said? Do we not listen to what
was just said?
This is actually crazy, man. >> This is what actually occurred,
but as far as what two adults do in terms of role play stuff,
I have
zero opinion on that stuff. I don't understand the relevance
at all.
It could be the wildest role play you could possibly imagine.
And I >> Question for Hutch. Do you think the role play
is the most concerning part of this story? Reading or listening
comprehension question. Is the role play an important part of
this
>> I just >> I don't think that's any of my business.
Uh you know, like there's some kinks where I'm like, that's a
little weird, but I you know, I and if there's things that like
in the past people have like
asked me to do things that I wasn't comfortable with, but I just
don't I just don't care. I just I don't think that that that
that it's relevant
to any kind of like discussion about someone's character.
I just don't care. People are into weird stuff, man. You just
everybody's everybody's got their weird stuff that they're into.
And I do not give if >> And yes, my outline is on Microsoft
Because [__] you, that's why. >> He 1,000%
accidentally that he did not mean to do that. >> willingness
to hold down
>> He pulls it up earlier in the stream and shows it. It
reads from it. >> in real life, then that is dangerous.
>> Dude, this >> I man, I don't I don't know what
the [__] to say at this point. Like honestly, if
you're dealing with allegations, like some allegation that somebody
would let someone
to not pay attention and then just go, "Oh my god, Connor's doling
caps."
That seems totally absurd. That seems like this is something
you probably shouldn't touch. If this is the level of engagement
you're going to give, if this is the effort you're going to put
in, holy Hutch, what is wrong with you? What is your problem,
man?
And yeah.
>> Listen, when two consenting adults want to discuss the
concept of letting the other adult [__] Well, I got
no problem with that." says Hutch, quote Hutch.
Wow, that's really cool, Hutch. Seems a little [__]
up for you to say that. That's just a little [__]
up. Me personally, I'm like, "Hey, if somebody's talking about
how turned on they are by the idea of letting another
like harm their >> I hate it too, Jerry. Yeah, I think
it's it's gross.
or positive to engage in a kink or roleplay.
I think it's bad.
>> Well, there we go. >> it's neutral or good
and you are a current member of my community, I ask one of two
things from
Why are we exploring the morality of kinks? You either keep that
opinion to
or you leave my community.
>> You down to hang out with people who do roleplay there,
Hutch? That involves like actual real Like as in they are the
object of the
Like cuz, you know, I'm not exactly
I'm not like a kink shamer, but it does feel like it's really
out of balance. Like, okay, you need to do something crazy like
that. Two two consenting adults and all that, but just make it
about somebody made up. Just make it about something You know
what I'm saying? Like don't don't put a real person into it,
dude. >> And if let's say that all of my oilers, all of
my chippers, all of my community support come from people who
think this is not a big deal.
>> Hutch can now purge a bunch of mods and followers from
this drama.
>> Yeah, I I I said it the last time. This is This is kind
of the text book definition of a uh a crash out, but this one
seems a bit >> And who think that it is perfectly sane
and rational for Steven to be
and hostile people while currently being sued for sexual misconduct.
>> PJ with $5, I guess I sort of know what he's trying
to get at, but it also feels like he's getting lazy and just
infantilizing people with mental illness. I he's certainly doing
that. >> I don't want your money.
I would rather destroy my streaming
and I would rather go back to working construction administration
as a nobody
who participates in this space as a
than continue to rely on your viewership or financial support.
I want that to be abundantly
clear. >> Thanks with the $2. Pretty sure Connor's having
a mental breakdown. I don't know. A mental breakdown is Maybe
that's a bit
strong the language. He's having what we might call an episode.
He's in it.
>> He's like in it right now. >> That's pretty crazy.
That's pretty
Uh but I still maintain like if he if he backed off a little
bit, took a break, decompressed for a little bit, maybe got some
couch time,
talked to a therapist or himself, then like it shouldn't be career
ending, you know what I mean? >> That if you thought that
I should have swept for this, if you thought that I should have
let sleeping dogs lie, if you think this is some kind of crash
out, I would like you to go to the Discord. I would like you
to click one of the settings buttons.
>> I just like Dude, it's it's pretty funny watching
a lot of people just dance around this stuff. Like they just
totally dance around it. >> And I will not be gaslit by
moral
>> We keep watching. >> into other perspectives.
thank you Hutch. Thank you Wick. Why is this all in the open?
I don't know. Why the [__] do I know about it?
Why do If this is Steven's personal
if this is his private life, and his private life is private,
even open. I don't know. Why the [__] do I know about
it?
Why do I
>> Connor makes good points. Connor, how did Connor know
about Destiny private
I had not considered this.
>> This is Steven's personal life. If this is his private
life, and his private life is private,
why do I know about it? Is it because he recklessly engaged with
mentally ill people who contacted me and told me about it? Is
that why? >> In private, right? Do they consent to you
talking about >> No, in public, you Oh,
I I'm so lucky I said there instead of something else. I was
so close. >> Public uh fresh paycheck with $5. If Destiny
wants to [__] his own life up, that's his prerogative.
>> They have dragged this out in public multiple times
now, Hutch. >> It's all over Connor is using that. >> In
fact, allow me to pull up one of the examples of it being brought
up in
Here's the husband. For those who don't know, Destiny's been
having an affair with a married woman with his girlfriend broke
up with him and threatened to expose him as a pedo. She had was
sending him pics of her This is the wife. I have proof. It was
my wife. We're split up now. That's why blank or whatever her
name is left him. They were doing weird H play stuff and she
sent him pics of my kids. No BH, I don't know what that is. She's
been in here, Brit. Delete the pictures of my off your computer,
you sick freak. Destiny solicits pictures of from mentally ill
housewives he made a blitz and I have proof. Acknowledge me,
freak. Pedo cult. Wow.
This is in public. This is in public in November of 2025.
Why is it in public? Well,
>> as a reason to condemn him. That's a level of personal
involvement that is uh not healthy, I would say. Lawson with
$5 Connor bless his heart >> I think this is what's unhealthy.
This like weird cultish lack of engagement. You don't know the
facts of what's happening. This is what's unhealthy,
You are justifying not paying attention. You're somehow justifying
to yourself. You're not paying attention and there are actual
like there's actual problematic behavior here. Possibly not even
from Destiny. That's the sad thing. You could run into a scenario
here where you could almost entirely make Destiny blameless.
But instead of actually engaging and figuring out what's going
wrong, you are just telling everybody else they're weird for
caring while spending hours of your day reviewing this vod. >> It
is also
not a crazy stance to say that Steven has over his friends, people
who care about him, and his professional relationships. Peace
going him, we're going to do a show together in 2024. He [__]
that up. Hutch, Josiah, IRI, me, Lonerbox, we would all love
to collaborate with Steven. He is a nuclear
stockpile
next to a case of dynamite. >> So, you just draw boundaries
around that stuff and live your life, you know? >> But
you haven't drawn a boundary, Hutch. You're reacting to his personal
life stuff right now. You haven't drawn a
You're drawing the personal stuff in is in your boundary. You're
commenting on it right now, which is particularly egregious cuz
you don't realize this
Somehow you don't realize you've put yourself inside the personal
life drama. You are commenting. You're as parasocial or weird
as Counter Points.
But you're also blinding yourself
So, like it's one thing to say, you know, somebody is really
traumatic in a parking lot and they say, "This person might"
It's one thing for you to go, "That's none of my business. I'm
sorry. Call the cops."
But if you start listening and you go, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's really weird that you're talking about this in public. Hey,
no. Hey, lady, shut the [__] up. It's weird you're
talking about this in public right now. Hey, lady, lady, shut
the [__] up." And she goes, "No, look at the evidence."
And And she don't look at the evidence. She just goes, "Weird
for you to be talking about this, [__] Hey, [__]
it's weird for you to be talking about this right now."
That's like what we're experiencing, right? He is not looking
at what's happening. He is quite literally telling people who
are aware of the situation that they should not be talking about
it without actually learning the facts of the matter.
>> Isn't role-playing as the step-parents of each other
just role-playing as being married? How is that inappropriate?
Well, when you [__]
When you [__] the it's inappropriate.
There's no way he just sits here and
faces when it's being laid out directly.
Real serious.
>> This year.
This is Britney.
Is he like on his phone?
Writing into Mr. Girl.
>> I was involved in an online affair with a guy for almost
a year. My husband wouldn't engage with any of the weird trauma
induced
>> kink stuff that I was curious about and so I was compelled
to impulsively and >> Guy's sick. >> regretfully
engage with this guy online in some pretty intense and taboo
age play scenarios including fantasizing about being step parents
to each other's
and obviously it went way too far but felt really intensely good
in the moment. But afterward I felt sick and cried all night.
>> But that doesn't say anything about
though. Am I crazy? Wasn't that just we were step
step parents to each other's When did it involve like
pretending like they were
>> This is Britney. >> This might be close to engagement.
Maybe could be close to engagement. Maybe maybe maybe. >> Writing
into Mr. Girl. >> I was involved in an online affair with
a guy for almost a year. My husband wouldn't engage with any
of the weird trauma induced kink stuff that I was curious about.
And so, I was compelled to impulsively and regrettably
regretfully engage with this guy online in some pretty intense
and taboo age play scenarios, including fantasizing about being
step parents to each other's
>> including fantasizing about being step parents to each
other's
>> And obviously, it went way too far, but
>> That's not
If you're both step parents, then you're not like pretending
like you're or whatever, right?
>> Dude. Dude.
>> I'm sorry. At this point, it's like Like and again,
I don't know how else to say it. I've said it so many times in
the same way. If he listened and he went, "You know what? That's
gross, but like I'm still not going to say unless it can get
her, I'm still not going to say." Like if he actually engaged,
but he is he is intentionally blinding himself.
He's intentionally not understanding. When they say, "And obviously,
it went way too far." What else would that mean? Nothing else.
It is incredibly specific and clear what is meant here, and Hutch
is pretending he can't understand.
>> Media literate >> Is he Is he going to >> Good
media literacy. Real serious. >> I'm sure they threw up
from imagining getting married and having sex with another adult.
You're doing great. >> Any thoughts? >> Any thoughts?
>> Good analysis. >> Any thoughts? >> Right,
because it obviously felt real bad, too.
How do you know if the other person also feels the same way or
if they would actually do it? My >> Do what?
There's nothing wrong here. It's just two consensual adults talking
about
having sex with each other. >> It's pig-latin. Is he like
about to start crying? Is he about to start crying? I feel like
>> What Why is she talking about being worried that the
other person might do >> And now, at minimum, I do think
that is the face of somebody who wishes they'd paid attention
for the past 2 hours. I do think Listen, he's going to get back
to sweeping, I'm positive, but right now, that is that is reality
setting in on somebody who did not pay attention for the past
2 hours, and they're realizing that they [__] up
doing it.
Uh dude,
that's that's crazy. He's going to go back to sweeping, I'm positive.
He'll you know, he'll he'll he'll get through this really fast.
But it's when it's laid out that slowly, I very much hope he's
got no way to wiggle out of trying to understand what's going
on here. >> She's just talking about them being married
and engaging in normal consensual adult She's not She's obviously
not talking about
>> understanding is the best predictors
are drug use and low empathy.
>> Uh and even worse, what if you felt like you love them
so much that you wouldn't care if they did, and you get off on
what you would potentially be willing to allow them to get away
with? >> Oh, clearly. They're just talking about consensual
adult sex.
Real serious.
Are you serious?
>> I swear if he doesn't engage during this, I'm
Say something. crazy pants.
>> Say something. >> proof of the Destiny's
I have the testimony of the husband.
>> Okay, like right? Like actual Like I'm sorry. If you
will not speak after that, you will not say that you understand,
you just were downplaying this, you said it was nothing, and
now it's been laid out for you so slowly, and you're still going
to pretend you don't understand what the allegation is. By the
way, you could hear all this, So, could still go, "Well, that
doesn't prove Destiny did anything."
You could still say that. But, you are you are denying what is
in front of your face in a way that is incredibly concerning,
man.
Holy [__] >> I have the testimony of the wife.
I have the wife writing into Mr. Girl. That's what I have. How
do you know for sure that he intentionally abuses mentally ill
women? It's probably not even intentional. It's probably
If Steven had explicitly told you he was going to do what he
was going to do and leave him alone if you don't like it, would
you have come public with this regardless? Probably.
If If it were true that Steven were compulsively engaging in
uh was compulsively engaging in um promiscuous behavior with
with other people, then then like both parties would be dealing
with mental illness in that spot. It's not just about like
>> Dude, he totally he totally ignores it. He totally just
ignores
That's sick.
This guy is sick, man.
This guy is
sick.
I'm telling you, this is the guy
Uh no, I Dude, I
I probably should just stop engaging with this dude's [__]
at all at this point. This guy is a sick
And by the way, that's without You could have Destiny be totally
innocent of everything here.
And it doesn't excuse what this stream is at all. It actually
doesn't excuse it in any way. Like it it it's actually divorced
now from what the reality of the Destiny situation is. He only
sees that he's getting an audience, that he's getting clout from
this connection, and he will defend anything. And he doesn't
care to look into whatever it is at all.
ill, man. This guy is like fun fundamentally foundationally